Good
evening
evening evening my name
is Paul Holden grave I'm the director of public programs here at the New York Public Library known
as LIVE FROM the New York Public Library as all of you know my goal at the library is to make
the Lion's
Roar to make a heavy institution downs and when successful to
make it levitate.
It is a pleasure to welcome Mary Louise Parker she was here. To welcome her back she was
here was Ryan Adams some years back and Mary Karr for the first but I
hope not the last time to be live from the New York Public Library after the
event which would last about as long as a psychoanalytical session if your shrink is
generous they will they
will both sign their books.
Upcoming two more events next week I will be interviewing Edmund a
while you may remember he wrote a magnificent
book called The here with amber eyes and now he's written a book
about the mysteries of whiteness in the form of porcelain.
Then in December the Robert Silver's lecture will be delivered this
year by Helen Vendler.
I would like to say a big thank you to the Ford Foundation for their fantastic
support of life from the New York Public Library ten Senate verse
three to celebrate the Ford Foundation will match your contribution to
alive dollar for dollar. When you give you will help. Make sure we
can continue to engage New Yorkers in conversations that contribute
to and enrich the
cultural discourse. Please consider giving with a pledge you will
find on your way out. Additionally I want to thank
the continuing generosity of Celeste barters and mend and Adam bottoms.
Essayist Mary Karr knows about writing a life. New book The Art
of memoir is an elegant exploration of one of today's most
popular literary form. Tonight. She's joined by actress Mary
Louise Parker because I'm conventional memoir in letters.
Dear Mr you was described by car as tense piecing
really funny and a magnificent necessary
surprise for reflection on the
show as many of you know for the last seven or eight years I've asked my
guests to provide me with a biography of themselves in seven
words seven words that may or may not describe them a haiku of
sorts so if you're very modern a tweet. Mary Louise
Parker submitted the seven words to
me I'm not dead yet.
Don't make
me.
Mary Karr submitted the seven words to me best
selling memoir wrist award winning
poet black belt sinner.
He's welcomed
them or
if.
There
are
actual
humans out there. Now I have to bury Louise
to begin by. By reading that section.
Well there are so many sections. The book she could have started with this is Dear Dr I
hope is that right. Towards the end this is the
end
of the letter to the doctor that say
he may be sitting next to you I have no.
I
got to watch people trying to save a life.
I felt mine pulled away and back in spurts of protest and
compliance from a completely different vantage point. I got to measure a length of
mortality against that infinite question mark best of all there is a
small
but distinct category of negative thought that I abandoned somewhere when I realized I only had
the strength to hold so much and something had to go. I can't
decide where existence lies or verily
dangles and Dr maybe you don't know either but I can tell you I am humbled by the
second chance. I don't know what death is but I'm one hundred percent clear on what it
isn't it isn't
my daughter refusing to try on a pair of shoes while the salesman admonished me for buying her the wrong
in souls and then leaving the store furious. As my daughter says I want you to know
I support you one hundred
percent. And today be the day I start drinking coffee and
also isn't the
dog digging a pack of gum out of my purse and chewing it then paying on the gum wrappers and crawling in
my lap making me forget to hate her. It isn't having the door handle to my office break
off in my hand when I realize my only keys are in there and then remembering that. Oh
yeah these are luxurious problems.
It isn't having too much to do and wanting to scream and it isn't screaming.
It might be poetry but it isn't sitting and hearing it read by my son. It isn't
him giving a standing ovation for the actor with the smallest part or my daughter confessing
that she lied and then doing a cartwheel it isn't getting
a whole email in the E.S.L. from my niece and not caring that it's been. Literally incorrect
because I laughed so hard while reading it that I actually cried tears.
It is an Antiques Road Show after sex for the sixth time while the sheets threaten
to disintegrate.
It isn't me listening to my children breathe at night and that being enough to want to keep
my heart pumping
blood that one. Mine was not the only heart you
saved Sure they might have used their last of their mother to fuel them
in life toward a greater purpose or maybe it would have been so damaging
that they'd never fully come back.
Thanks to you I don't have to watch either of those scenarios play out while perched on a
cloud fighting with God to let me intercede or spend eternity aching
to at least become the quivering sunbeam that lands on them one morning when they roll out of
bed age twenty
five
as my friend Father Bob says medicine can be more art than science.
I believe the best doctors are a particular category
of artist with the creator's instinct to throw something on a canvas
and start expanding which must come down to divinity and the ability to judge
what would bleed well into
what it was too scary for me to face my
body giving me warnings of being so screamingly temporary. I wonder
how often we are being nudged But we turn away. We find a place to jettison
all of
it or hand it to someone and say here. Please organize this for me
I can't stand it.
It would be eeriest those warnings lingered somewhere the sound of
them run
home. Don't answer the door or walk away from Him
Now what if that lasted.
If only I knew what last meant there is no now.
My father would say banging his cane on the floor on the word now as soon
as you say the word it's. Already in the past when is it. There isn't one.
This is the only moment and it has already passed the only thing says
spending
time are children and cross-country travel not even all our stars
are moving that was light years ago. It's only us here dying as slowly
as we can.
Lose
if
you're another section we're going to read.
Now as for you and I are going to read. I guess later harder than
when everybody's bored. OK. This will save it will save it and say I'm
going lighter. Like all the death actually were done now.
That was it that was the whole
event
you know your book store I read your book today. It's like the fourth time I read
this and I didn't intend to reread it I intended to skim it
and what people don't know about Mary Louise is she reads a lot of poetry so there's a lot
of poetry in the
book but it starts with gratitude.
To you who can fix my screen door. My attitude
and open most jars to you who
codified slams a park built a decent cabinet or the
perfect sandwich use or you took my order my
pole my
bullshit.
Were you a daddy's
girl. I still am daddy's
girl why it's never did I think that that's a terminal condition and I bet
that one doesn't stop you don't die from it that well.
Played
out by it. I think it's funny that you.
Mentioned poetry
in gratitude and the same sentence like that because I
was I was really reading your book Devil's Tower
and I was struck by the way you
said poetry never left you stranded and I
feel that's what I always got from poetry is feeling like you know if
you're someone who grew up and
people
tend to roll your eyes if you're an actress and you say that you're a loner but you just have to take my
word for it or you can talk to whoever wants my high school
but. If you grew up and all were someone who ever felt
lonely or isolated or you know separate
there is something about the distilled experience and in the spray of words like on the
page that just for me made me feel
less alone in a way
that that movies didn't or are or
are not even necessarily fiction.
Sometimes but you read poetry am I wrong almost exclusively like you read
more poetry than script I read more nonfiction or not to read too
many scripts Yeah but I read poetry.
Mostly
I do read other things I love short stories I love and know Briain and
deadly EISENBERG And that's what I do read an awful lot of poetry Yeah.
Why do you think every This this book for those of you haven't read it it's
a kind of love poem to the masculine involving fathers
grandfathers
sons daughters of people a guy
named Tarzan who wears a loincloth and I don't think you actually dated there
were something going on there.
Why is everybody so mad at
Boyce Thank you I mean actually we know why they're mad at boy. Why
don't they buy out your baby Here's
one now show us your stuff.
I feel like if I were to get a write a book
about the masculine and men I mean
who in the end who love
men more than me and maybe that's we can go to the mat
about that later
but yeah I do love men and I and I
was raised by this extraordinary man and I was lucky enough to meet these
men throughout my life who with little maybe what might be forgotten gestures
or even relationships or moments that loomed kind of
ironic for me in my life.
You know the boy that I didn't really I didn't know his
name and that I saw in the hospital
or there's your legacy like your big
C. big feet. I do have
an appreciation for what is
male despite being almost again
terminally female myself in many ways almost tragically so
but there I do love men and I
have spent a good deal of my life trying to figure out why I
was forfeiting
parts of myself in exchange for that a certain kind of attention from
them or.
Give me a print or printed I think Santa love that God Well I happen to have
a several hundred of those are. Available to you for a pittance. I
think I
think my friend I think this is the book.
Joe when he first saw me in college used to call me the girl without a spine because I
was always draped on some
guy you know and I think it came from being such a
wallflower that once I was out of my cage and I found that I figured out how
that one worked. I wanted to play with that toy
all the time I
didn't want to let go of it and I wanted this one and that it was just sort of an
insatiable they that wasn't always entirely
only sexual or romantic either.
You know and suddenly when I was at college I suddenly had all these game male friends that I never had in high
school in Arizona nobody was out of the closet when I was a high school. Suddenly they wanted to borrow
my pantyhose and do their makeup and I was like I was in heaven I was like a whole different
side. Of men that I didn't
know which is also reflected in the book.
She Mary Louise has at the at one point very early in the book one of my
favorite hitchhiking song signs of all time. Marin
County please. We've read
start you know it work
let's that's a really critical area because when you're just outside of Berkeley.
That's how you have picked up it works really fast and I don't like the meeting so you had to hide
the boys. They met and they pushed me out on
the corner by the off ramp and made me pull my skirt up which was already. You know.
Yeah out in Philly High and pulled my shirt off my shoulder
and get us a ride and as soon as somebody stopped they would
pile in the back which you should not do now ever hitchhiking is not
safe now even in Berkeley.
But wasn't safe then I mean Ted Bundy was cruising looking for you.
Yeah I didn't know about that. They didn't tell me that who did.
Yeah we did it on a guy doing a cheesy. Right. Well you know
hitchhiking it's a slippery slope. Let's just leave
the.
Girls got to get from one side of the bridge to the other you know. Do you know what to talk about to your blue I'm sorry I
love him you know I know you don't gripe to them how he what he wore because it's
an in. Trysting Well you know I don't try all he could read that your way. Now because
it's better than my saying it when I
was very young
I worked in a health
food sort of co-op. It's kind of a legendary
place and you're it's
not called per se but there were
cultish aspects to it and it was at a time when there were no begins there was
no people didn't put chia seeds in their front but you know things like that it
was really a way different time and spear Lino was something exotic
anyway and I was living near the beach
and I never wear shoes and that was like one
particular chapter and I met this guy whose name was blue. This
is the letter I write to him Dear Lou.
Did you sell it. I'm just trying to imagine where you got
it there was no such thing as Amazon yet and I'd never seen one except on
Tarzan your loincloth But did you use fabric from an old
couch but didn't have a couch. Maybe you liberated a square of fabric from your
teepee or stitched together some burlap bags that once held a hydroponic
fertiliser you wore that cloth on your loins every day so maybe there was even
a
spare when you were a fruitarian eating nothing but fruit and nuts.
Though apparently beer was the fruit of a van illegally parked on
the beach not beside it on it was your home and you needed no shirt shoes
nothing you and your friend Gary drove to the border at dawn to get avocados and
fix for the co-op where I worked also and then you went to the beach if you had no one to Rolf you were
all for massaging those lucky people while wearing nothing or your
loincloth OK maybe a piece of jewelry was also on your
body a necklace but that was it you and Gary both had
gorgeous ocean so care that was longer than. Mine. Gary had a mane of
chestnut that might have made him rich if you don't been
to seven stations of the cross theme park your hair was its
own Disneyland it glowed in the dark from salt water and sun that hair gave
you the vibe of being both switched on and overcooked at the same time.
You were the only man I've ever seen who could wear your hair in a bun with a flower and not
seem sissy. You had sold patches and
Tans period. Diving in the surf might happen five times a day and how could you lie down at
the tide and feel sand rushing everywhere if you were wearing clothes when you took me to
that nude beach up the coast taking off your loin cloth seemed brazen a
dog could walk away with your entire
wardrobe.
Ripping it off was a breeze though and you threw yourself into the water leaving me an op how little there
was between you in the world. It took hardly anything to be not just happy but filled with
a kind of alien joy.
You took anyone's idea of modern life and set it on fire decades
before anyone dreamed up burning man. You didn't need
to rent an R.V. with wife I and stuck up at Whole Foods to drive somewhere and let the madman and your
third eye. You've found it had it and let it in and had it going on and out again.
Even your name which you said had become you after you dropped acid and were sitting on
a massive rock by the
cliffs when you opened your eyes everything including you was blue
except your loin cloth which for the summer I knew you was a light brown man wrap that
made you and Gary look
like Malibu Jesus dolls. And kept you from being arrested for indecent exposure by
more or less covering your genitalia you and Gary would come into the co-op first thing in
the morning
with many report and pouring out of your van the two of you with pelt me with flowers while I sat in
the back of the stock room bagging and weighing organic knots and bizarre dried
sea vegetables. Back then only the hardcore who came into our store even knew
about dried
kelp in the eighties. Only true
hippies bought sparely in a bag and snorted it or however they took it one side bag
and labeled it probably incorrectly and priced it most definitely incorrectly.
Somedays joining me at the scale was a sweet and sellin transgender boy named
Lux who wasn't much better than I was we got in trouble for throwing a block of gouda up
at the ceiling fan to see if it would come down in chunks. They separated us.
They had one of
us bag while the other stuck dairy which meant standing in the refrigerator and replenishing all the yogurt
and Kieffer and freezing our asses off. I found the scale confusing and was never good
at math.
So I'd spend hours getting yelled at by that girl named Jackie who was a higher up. I heard
you used to date her which I had a hard time picturing Jackie dressed in
those macrame tops that she made in tie
dyed and she sewed her own maxi pads with inspiring words in Don and be
used to make her connect to her
Yoni I don't know if you were into this also but janky drank her pee
which once she blew in my face lightly. Then ask me Hey does my breath smell like
urine was brave in a way but she was hard to admire because she had Mohnish me daily
for being an app.
She said my mistakes made her feel confused and out of touch freshly
punished I go back to my station
and try to get the plankton or ground Macia out from under my nails wishing I didn't have to work two
jobs or that one of them didn't have to be this
one which sometimes paid me and
avocados.
That Lucy was
really kind
of a beautiful guy and I say that in the true hippie sense
the she was switched on he
had actually emanated some kind
of light and I remember before I went into work my first day somebody said
to me
see if you meet this guy blue I want to hear what you think about him.
And I just remember turn around and this guy was like it was as though he had his own light source
behind him sort
of all he read was a
halo he was beautiful and he was beautiful inside
and out he
really did you I didn't understand your relationship is that somebody you actually
went out with I wouldn't say we
went out the door but I didn't. There was no there was not a
lot of out. Not about to go to there were you were
out is the town was outdoors he.
I'm trying to obscure his identity
but I wouldn't say we went out. But that we had an appreciation
for one another that.
Dear papa you said you would love me till you were ashes. But there we
see him poor guy has told us to I know he does this how could he not. I know how you feel.
You'll have to fight me. But they're not all they're not all glorious
these men you come across there
is is that Sara boasters river a Serb or
us the dog that guards the gates of hell the three headed
dog you dated him. All three of him.
Many had to
arrive. Can you explain how you landed on Sir sir sir Bruce for
him for this dude why I love
to have to kind of explain
why I use that method for telling
that story but really it was just kind of a cool all right like a fairy tale and then I can use
a different font at the
beginning
but it was in the end what made it work for me was
that I wanted I needed to waited to recount these relationships because they were
a huge part of my life and some of them were punitive and dead and ugly.
And I thought it would be effective to tell it in a way where you know when
you remember. Things. Everything becomes completely polarized and you're completely
innocent and the story and the other person is
demonic and this I wanted to say it as well I
wanted I
wanted to sort of almost do a cartoon version of that and I thought it would.
Then it would give the story levity. Because what I didn't want to do
was seem like I was asking for sympathy or elicit any kind
of you know because I was complicit in that I laid down for it
I asked for it I I conjured it I even pulled it out of people I think at
times and it's also a conversation that I still have with myself that I don't fully
understand I think if you had more than one relationship that
wasn't ideal rock to tell you
know mostly so many
beautiful relationships but I have had a handful you know I'm fifty one years old
that were not awesome and you do end up having that conversation with yourself
over time why did I do that why don't love that it's like my mother
was married seven times I always thought that once you have figured it out
or will know at what point do you
say maybe it's not them.
Right.
Is it number three number four. Now it's like you're picking
them lady like is what I was saying throughout that is like this is essentially the
same man just sprouting a new head that since there was nothing for them but a kind of
pants
that you know to me that's one of the most
I'm in some ways moving it in
realistic portraits I mean there are there ARE
NOT do you think you're too hard on yourself. I mean I often thought I think so
yeah I mean as I was reading those even
despite naming somebody after three headed dog guards the gates of hell.
You to you seemed to me like your berry. If there was an asshole in the
book it's often you. Yeah. Yeah my role in my wrong well I'm not going to write a book where
I'm indicting other people and if I'm going to if there are needs to be a foil I can use I have plenty of
material to use myself for you
know. I didn't but it's such a funny book it's such
a funny book I didn't want this book to be in any
way I feel like we're in a culture of it seems to be there's a
new witch hunt every day you know there's like everyone's exposing something or
someone and there's you know
tends to Lebanese who have three nipples or something like that or click here a few
you know. Horrible pictures of people at the grocery store it just I
feel there's enough exposure in a damning way that
why
not there are so many instances in my life that I'm so
grateful for someone who shine a light on me for one moment
or showed me some kind of kindness like a my accountant or the
doctor my friend Adam or so many people my friend
Jeff can I just feel that I just read the introduction a dear A I
just have love for these people. I wanted to write something that was nice
there Abraham you took me in when I scratched at your door needing somebody with your
skill set. How you feel about your account and I just met a bi want
him to be my account now he did he
did
treated me and still treats me like you saw like a daughter he treats me with
such love and care
and who can say that about their
accounts because so far for me and it it's not even when he met me I
was
this girl.
I was completely broke he had to tell me I was broke because I didn't know I couldn't understand my
bank statements and he had to explain them to me and break the news to me the unfortunate news that
I had
absolutely no money. Because I'd spent it all I had bought I'd just gotten
a little bit
of money and used. A credit card and so other
funds and gotten a pool table for a boy and he had to tell me you could
not afford that pool table
and I became very depressed and I thought I could sleep on his
couch and I took a nap on his couch and he just kind of sat there and stared at me for a couple of hours
and it's not like I was somebody that he was impressed with or that I was just a
girl in his office or just wandered in you know who really did
need guidance and who needed his help and he gave it to me for no other reason that
he was kind and
he felt a connection to me you think people are phrase it was Q U R Q
That is cute now but I was cute then I think you're way huger than you were.
I think your cuteness quotient is rising. My personal opinion.
Do you think people are afraid to say they need something. Do you think now I mean we're talking
about talking about the kind of outrage culture one of the things I was moved
to that moved me about these pages. And I had
a sort of I had to interview or somebody
said. You know when you have
celebrity books in the back of your book suggesting that people read them and this
is somebody I mean you can tell by the prose this is not.
This is not look at my titties at the afterparty kind of prose
I mean it was years ago. Yeah. It was years ago for all of us.
Yeah. But do you think people to me what I look part of what
I loved about the book was his sense of true not afraid to say what you need you're
not afraid to go to sleep on Abraham's count. I would be
terrified. Honestly I felt most of my life afraid to say to
ask for
things. And I often
felt more of an observer which is why I think I have a fairly keen memory
for details of of moments that I observe. Didn't other people or expressions or things that
I saw wash over people's faces
or things that they said those kind of things I remember.
So so acutely and it's from being the person who was
watching and I never
felt brave enough
to ask for things and I still don't. And it's funny because I remember
that moment with him and I barely remember. Can I sleep on your couch but he remembers and.
I remember that he asked me if I wanted something to eat and I was starving and I said
no I wasn't starving
but I was really hungry and I said no this is not what
we do that these women you're not supposed to eat too much. Well you know just because of someone says Would you like
this can I get you something to drink. So let's I can let's start saying yes from now on for anything.
Almost everybody here if we all pinky swear
we set out tomorrow with that as a goal and we've got a shot.
But you do seem to remember very keenly. And I'm often accused of making things
up when I
say I remember so do you think why do you do you think you have a particularly
physical memory because the book seems to me to have a lot
of physical details and I think I over invest in other people and I over
connect to other people and that's why
my relationships are so intense sometimes because it's got that release that you get when you
feel seen suddenly you know which is at war with. The
majority of Me What's hates to be looked
at you know I do I do crave being you know you want to be
really seen by someone and connecting to somebody is paying
attention to them and what do they need
and what are they thinking and what do they want for Christmas and and oh I just saw
them touch that tire went out you know those kind of things I
remember. And it's over connecting that which makes me disconnect from other things
which
makes me leave the mail in the freezer. You know that makes
me forget huge chunks of the day. Or it's.
It's and it's not that I'm saying I'm so martyred or I'm so saintly that I'm over connected I'm not sure that
that's necessarily a good trait. Sometimes it is and sometimes it comes out
of a generosity and sometimes it comes out of me
need you know and it's hard to say which is which I mean I'm not
really probably self-aware enough to say which one
is acting at which
point you know when when you're being generous we want to believe that all our
generous gestures come
from goodness but sometimes they come out of need. I
think need to feel like a good person but it feels like if it isn't at all that
So isn't it also need to be
there and need to connect to someone in need to be
needed feel less lonely. I mean that's not feel less lonely to cheer being only
don't like meeting those shoes but then use I know they're so good but then you.
She told me sequins were in general they are the same No they
are bad show is for and you heard it here on ISSUES
Mary said Yeah she said she looked
at him she said Booker
please. Yeah I respect that.
I do I do feel like if
you if you are aware of when
when you're acting out of need then then you can be aware when you have a
truly generous gesture when you are being completely selfless when you really
know when that is that that there's a difference between the two does that make any
sense. I've seen you with your kids and you're an incredibly generous mother
get two beautiful beautiful children a son and daughter you got one of
each I only have one but I'm sprouting another.
Recruit it. I recruited a daughter through my son. But what
are you. What kind of mother are you it's not even a pure question to ask or
you it. I mean it
seems to me just as your. Friend or someone who seeing you with your kids you
seem me didn't you have like the whole why Young Thing night or something I mean was in that.
We
have around the
world nights where it's do we do like we do Evening
in Paris and we'd played Piaf and make you know French
food and then we dress. You know where the red robe or re
you speak French and we did evening in Japan. We did evening in the middle ages and we all
ate drumsticks have a go sounds of some things I thought yeah
it does things like game nights we'd have a way that doesn't seem
like that kind of household but I mean who really thinks of that we've
been Was your mother that kind of mother was your father that kind of
father couldn't couldn't be that kind of money and she had four children should not have anyone helping her at
all and you know there's times when my dad didn't have a
job and you know my dad was looking for work or he was at work and she was just
trying to get food on the table and get us taken care
of and I mean to be
a single mother is a different kind of pressure but. I have
had the luxury at times because my job allows me when I do
work I work very intensive hours but then I have times when I'm off and I can
take them to school every single morning and I can be the one that puts them to bed
at night and if I can be I will
be and it's much more interesting to me than going
out and going anywhere. It's just it's much more fulfilling
for me it fortifies me and in the way I I wanted my whole life. You know I wanted
that as did you how do you feel about I know your son is interested in
acting your daughter no she's she
us. She's very artistic very artistic she's an incredible
visual artist she's a she's a beautiful singing voice.
She plays beautiful piano and she. I think she does have a bit of a clown about her as well
so but you know you don't really know
my son is a great writer
and perhaps unfortunately seems to
be a bit of an actor.
But you wouldn't discourage them as long as one of the largest anything because I think I really
got that from my father
who he felt like it was not his place to give advice
and even when I went to college I went to drama school and you could
take minimal
minimal academics classes
and get a B.A. and I said I think those are going to interfere with my arts class and my dad
said
OK. And he said I think now my kids came to me and said basically I'm going to go
to college for four years but I'm not going to have a
B.A. what would I say. And because of my father I would say OK you know what you're
doing because that's what he said to me I said I'm going to be an actress. So I
don't need to go study Gian. I have like one geometry class once a week which
I'm going to fail anyway. You know if
you're your movement teacher was not as encouraging to you that there's a
chapter here called Fear movement teacher what was your failure in movement class you seem to be able to walk talk.
What
was it that he wanted to let you explain really what he wanted you to do it was unclear at
the beginning to be. He really took
a dislike to
me and I ever learned over the course of my life that
I have it's can sense
tough give off some kind of vibe that is strong. When I come
into Rome I suppose he didn't like me and but at this point
in my life I wasn't paranoid and he really didn't like me at this point in your life you were wearing opera gloves
to breakfast here and.
And I felt sort of per. Secured
it by that and he wrote an evaluation
that sort of detailed what I wasn't doing in the
class and. What I was doing that was not acceptable like lack of physical
energy is alarming it appears doubt and
board asks offensive questions. What's an
example actuality is offensive. But
he wrote this evaluation and put me on Art's probation and at first I felt
our probation.
We're going to take your arts away from you but he I felt super persecuted and then a
friend of mine said to me What are you going to do about
that and it was one of those moments in my
life where I was just able to hear the truth and at first
I was kind of slapped I felt really stung and
I would I mean what am I going to do he hates me and you know you expect your friends to
say yeah these are evil and.
And he said no he's a teacher and suddenly I was struck by
the fact there's. This the truth in that
was intractable it was just irrefutable. He's the teacher and I'm the stupid There's nothing I could say back
and I realized and it was invigorating that moment it was
a slap in the face but it really inspired me and I thought he doesn't like me
and it didn't happen in that moment but it happened.
Almost in that exact moment that I thought I'm going to see if I can
do what he's asking me to
do and I'm going to find respect for this person which I found an immense
respect for him and he was right about everything that he thought about me because he was
the teacher and that was his class and I He allowed
me in he let me change his mind about me which
was so generous because I learned that lesson that just because someone likes you doesn't
mean they're immediately dismissible And just because someone likes you doesn't
mean you can't change their. Mind and just because someone likes you doesn't
mean it's any of your business as to why.
But in in that instance he was right and it was appropriate for
me to try
to
to try to be the student you want to be and I did and he let me and it was it was a massive lesson for me.
You could have been a writer I mean not to anyone would want to be a writer you never get out of
your apartment or your pajamas.
What possessed you to go in this whole other direction I mean I see you as somebody who's a
very in some ways I mean you're just you're reading habits
are fairly sophisticated but why wouldn't you why wouldn't you
set out what possessed you what is it about acting that helped so galvanizing for
you that's really the more interesting question and nobody's asked me that is why did you
become an actress because my mother keeps
saying. I think vindicated.
I said all along you were going
to be a writer my prophecy she said to me the other day literally
my prophecy has come true.
Everyone knows this Mel. And she really did say
that that she felt I was a writer and my whole life
that's what I did I made little books and I rode and and then
once upon a time. David Grange or let me write for Esquire and started letting me write more and more and more
and
I I felt validated in a way that I had never
felt in my whole life except for my
dad. And his appreciation of me
and David Grange or specifically. DAVID Yeah he liked
my writing and he asked me to write another one and and so you know I started with
one column one piece
and. And they I sent it in
and they asked me if I had. Written and I says Well yeah I mean I get
my boyfriend to write.
And they said we need to cut it it's really good we might want to cut it and I said how many words
and they said I don't like this many and I said let me do it and I got it and I sent it back
it's really really good and they said complimentary things
and then they asked me to write another one and then another one and then over time.
And it was very male centric I got to write about men a lot so I got to really.
Meditate on that that it's not what I was thinking about anyway but.
So it really is the question why did I become an actor why did you tell me that I was for him over the interesting
because no one there really is that whereas me the body ever asked me why I didn't become an actress but I
miss I think you said of I don't think
so. I'm a short person of
so many of them are short you have no idea that really stand on boxes. Yeah. Yeah.
So I don't know how I feel I was put on a stage. At about the age
of four and I was
super quiet and shy and I stuttered I
still if I'm extremely nervous will start or sometimes.
And our Evan was a little bit
nervous that I was getting up on the stage foot for some tap rehearsal or something I was
doing a dance called the Chicken bop with my brother somewhere in America but
I don't know what it had to do with chicken at all I had a yellow costume
on and I got up on stage and the two other little girls started
crying took their little tutu tool things off head dresses
off and I walked out there almost alone and was
just happy to be there
certainly knowing how to dance or how to sell that dance even if I didn't
dance and there's a picture of me right before I walk onstage it's not really pictures of me on the stage and I looked.
So unbelievably relaxed I'm lying there like four years old and I have this like yellow.
Today. And I get up
there and it just felt. And I know it because
I've seen it in my son when he gets up I've seen it. I know
it you just some people you put them there and it doesn't matter how
afraid of of of other people they are how shy
they are or aren't.
It's just in some P.P. mind talking about the play I saw you in last
year I love Heisenberg Heisenberg A.B.C. the play.
They say they
say can I tell you my idea of hell is a play with two people in it
and you know I don't know I'd always feel like it's going to be Beckett or
towards some aspect of Beckett or somebody who I want you know not that has to be somebody wants to be Beckett.
And I'm going to be hell.
And
you beat the shit out of that play. Thank
You can you talk a little bit
about what I love that Iran Syria and you talk about little bit about that but I just
loved it
and. That writer. Simon Stevens who
wrote Curious Incident of the dog.
He just wrote y'all might know that's why I write this.
And Lynn Maddow of Manhattan Theatre Club I've done like six plays or
something on a day when I was having an alone moment in acting and I said
I doubt. Thank you just asked her she said I don't
accept your
retirement and I'm sending you a play right now and she's that has hired me since
I was twenty three years old or something like that and she sent this play and I knew by page four.
So met her. Can you tell them it's a privilege does a play allow just say a
little bit about what the premise of
the play was to stream Lee lonely people meet each other but it's really about
Heisenberg the. Principle in physics where if you observe something
closely enough you can never predict where it's going to go or where it is or
how far away it is because and I think this is part of it. That
which I love it so poetic this aspect of physics to me is
that the observer always interferes with the measurement and it so that you have to take yourself out of
any equation to know how far or how close you are to
something which is just so with have a poet with
a hard role for you.
Yeah but I am really only like the hard ones. I wouldn't want to do a play.
You know with people kind of lunching in the Hamptons
and you know I know that could be dialogue. I was with
and if I have to feel
like somebody like beat the hell out of me every night I it's not worth
it for me.
Did your mother want you to be a
writer was she like him best you didn't know she just
I thought to me because I was always reading and I was always writing and I was too
shy
and and yet when they put you on stage it was like the
lips that they didn't show me you know I don't I think if I wanted to not go they would have. But they
didn't expect me to run out there. I think is what happened.
I don't know that I don't know I do remember the feeling though and I remember the feeling
of performing even on a tiny
level really in some ways this book is an homage.
I think to your father. Now I think in many ways one of my one of
my one of my favorite or one of the most moving I buy
and sell myself crying at several places in one of the places was when
your son was saying Isn't it amazing all the different things we get to do
and aren't we so lucky to be alive and you said
addressing. Your your father who lives on the other side of the grass.
That's you and him.
Yeah that that capacity.
For astonishment and
that capacity
to to marvel at beauty really.
Unabashedly no
shame. And how that's going to make you appear.
Some people are embarrassed to do that to really sort of.
Revel in something
or marvel at it and my son really has
that one hundred percent. He can lose himself in something that he loves so it's that it's
a lot of hyperbole lot of emphasis.
Shared between my father my son myself. Everything is so in
phatic with what my daughter's so lovely because then she kind of like this sort of.
Equalizing force. You know like she's much. She's more
reasonable but true but your dad was and she's nine and she's probably going to have
to drive everyone she's
like that's right I can't drive a car that my son probably sorry honey should not
drive a car. Some of the day that you're a Marine Yeah there's danger from others not drive should
not be armed and should not be able to drive not be armed never
Yeah you know just now you've got exactly and I'm against guns and I but I'm mostly
against
guns somewhere handing me what Yeah you don't want one now that I don't when I don't have one. Neither of those should be
or no.
No
but. The driving thing is I feel like you're always driving and you always have
people say like you should not be all that try and I feel
like people are is that why don't you drive and I think I'm the person that you shout
at like Lady. You shouldn't have a my view of might think
I am that person I'm saving the
world maybe my in a way if
only when pressed or you know I'm my cv show I would drive
and the whole transpo I'd love that. Department so much they way they
tried so hard to teach me
to drive they would come out and watch sometimes if I had to drive just because it was
funny
watching me. Yeah. You shouldn't be allowed to drive your dad
was another favorite. Another highlight for me was your grandfather when your
father was in the war. Yeah. Send him a
cake. Yeah he was a drinker a parent did him a cake
with and father with this secret surprise and who I'd not met in the middle of World War
two
and he carved the guts out of the cake.
He's a coal miner and small town West Virginia carve inside out of a cake out
of it wasn't an actual cake it was a loaf of rye bread that is a day
old love of rye bread carved the got out and laid the bottle of
Moon chime in in the bread and then sealed
it and tried to ice it and mailed it to my
father in the Philippines as a birthday gift as a birthday open it up and
he knew he saw this this sort of like a horrible moldy
bald Reich a dry hooch cake
and he knew it was he knew there was something inside because it
was from his dad who was another larger than
life character who never you never met him I didn't. But obviously
and inspired me like I got to meet him by writing it and that
was I got so much permission first of all
from my agent Eric Simon off because I feel I know I wouldn't have written the
book without him because he really I would have sat around for another decade and gone.
I could write about that and even did that with him for a couple weeks so that I feel like
everything connects to astronomy now and then I should call it called Black
Dwarf and I called Black four for about two weeks to is like no why don't we move. Back
to just the men that
are and you just you know I would jam with this idea that he sort
of anointed and made me feel that it was good and sort of just gave me just the perfect
amount of encouragement at the
right pitch that I could hear and I there wouldn't be a book if wasn't for that and then with
man and Graham and Col and Harrison just to have them
like give me that freedom and say oh you can you certainly you can write
this other chapter and call and one day giving me a massive gift
by saying what I thought I'd written this piece about my father and him saying you
have begun to write about your father and that to me was like one of the biggest
guess that I know that I learned that's one of the oh shit moment. Because then I found the last
piece in
the book and I wouldn't have if you had said that I remember when he said it I felt it just put ice in my veins but in
a good way I thought my brain just started working and it was just him
giving me that permission to drive in that do you have another book in you.
Well I do I mean I have to have Eric will have to tell me what they are about.
You can read about me that's what I'll do
as well maybe a P.G. thirteen
but I know I do I do I have I mean I
have a lot of things written already it's just the idea for me
is to distill them and put them in one direction is difficult sometimes because
I get overwhelmed by choice but it's the real that compels you rather than
my imagination like you get sparked
by the truth and by my
experience
and these little things that have happened to me in my life these little
moments are when I first saw my friend sing at a club. It just brought back
everything including these little bowls of popcorn on the table you know like thirty years
ago and so many things like
that there's a lot of garbage in this book I think I mean I know that I.
People don't think of you as a God person but Nabby it's a book for your kind of combing through your
the universe looking for spiritual highlights which are almost always
moments of connection or admiration or rage or love for holier
eighty Well it's a I mean for me it's
a it's a conversation it's an ongoing conversation and
it's it's a search and
it's and the the words that you use and so cliche it's difficult to.
To sort of.
Put a name to it but it is something that I look for and I do go to church and I go to
different kinds of churches
and and I have moments where it's very hard for me to
remember my religion or remember God or remember like on the verite and
the moments where I rage against
it but I was
the first priest that I knew as a little girl was this amazing man is in
the book who.
I was involved with different from other men and he was he was gay which
I kind of knew on a cellular level my parents knew but no one ever talked
about it and chain smoked
and. You know drank a whiskey and
was
just the most pure hearted and still is wonderful man
who I asked him when I was nine years old and that's one of the moments I remember in my
life is there anyone in hell and we were still in church and I reached up and asked him I don't know
what provoked me I had to know in that moment and I just remember that his that
all of a his response is kind of wonderful he considered he considered might be thought
about
it and the fact that he considered it to me met.
Oh you
can you can make it up you can think about it you
can arrive at it it can be your opinion and it can
be an instinct. It can
be your own relationship with God It doesn't have to be what. Someone tells you it is
it doesn't have to be he didn't say this verse
this this but he said but he said like now you know yeah but he thought she didn't need any of
the Holy Ghost said it. Wow now and I said.
And he's
no. And I will never forget that in my head I
live bathed in relief exactly oh so much better exactly as but
it made I saw that it was his opinion and he approached it. Like I was
allowed to have my own opinion as well and still be a spiritual
person. And I tried to do that with my children as well. One day one of my
children
said I'm feeling kind of sixty forty about the
cross thing about did he come down off
the cross or not. Sixty five maybe Did you know
thirty five maybe did I said
OK let's let's talk about that and see how you feel when you go in there.
If you feel that way after its OK to feel whatever you want to feel or think whatever you want to think and
take from
religion or not what you can. But if you do
take there is
something there sitting in the room with a bunch of people who are
trying
to arrive at something to be better people and if you find those rooms then religion
is extremely useful if you find rooms that shut their door or their windows or
even shut their doors just a crack. Those are the rooms that exclude and you don't want to be in
those rooms but there are rooms in the world where people are trying to find
that and those rooms I believe shoot something up into the
stratosphere the New York Public Library. Is one it is right
is is a cathedral for me. I mean I think books Yeah those are the first lady. For those of us who are
book people I think salute leave but where else do we find God I mean you bring
your little lonely Ansin off. Forty second right. You get to see the big lions and
sit in the reading
room and I read this poem the other day that Michael taken my.
Literary publicist gave me
that. Linda Linda Greg poem and I'm obsessed with her right now.
Gnostics on trial and I just made my head explode and I thought.
Just those moments when when somebody makes something so clear within the space of
a first or a stanza. It just hits me like it's like a shot of tequila
or slap on the face but a good slap if there are good slaps there a good slap there
are good and lower lows that let's tell retarded some we're not supposed to say them. OK.
You promised me you were going to we should probably be wrapping up but you promised me you were going to
read another piece.
Can we can we have a send off
which would YOU can we have a sendoff piece.
Eric's time enough we want to
hear.
Your phone this little our dear little Al dear orderly dear orderly.
What is the future and future man that's
good dear future man who loves my daughter.
Oh yeah. First of all show up a
bit late. It may be better if she's seen a little of the opposite of you
and relaxes in your arms only when she realizes you don't have a gruesome face hiding under the one
you first showed her do not have another face hiding. Yeah I really
would
not have been
late but not so late that she doesn't trust it when you say you want to make her drunk on
happiness make her drunk on happy.
Make her unhappy.
Put yourself first do that awhile do it long enough so that she
suffers when she is done with that suffering which will only make her more
compassionate watch as she rises up like the seas last wave. Crushes you
with silence. Notice how that silence moves in on you as she
speaks telling you that she's had enough and you have to change. You will see her mouth moving
and recognize the words falling out and forming sentences that
mean quit this moment or I will quit you. But the quiet that continues
to threaten with staying forever if you don't comply. That is so much louder than her
words she will not be crying are begging she will realize she is powerful
and perfect alone and that she doesn't need
you her commitment to those words will terrify
you careful with metaphor as by then her
mother's overuse of it may have exhausted her and made her immune to
poetry remind her about poetry. If she has
given your children remind yourself every day of the second third fourth fifth and
sixth
words in this
sentence if you hurt her in ways that are reparable I will send people
out to hurt you back sorry but it has to be like
that this is the yes you may have had a difficult childhood but please allow me
to introduce myself. Hello I am the woman who doesn't give a shit.
Make her something warm
to drink in the mornings and give her time to begin speaking only Russian her with an embrace or
a gemstone wildflowers a love note the
Eights do not fight with her in public this almost includes the
dog she has an elegance that should not be polluted by compromising her
privacy this has something to do with loyalty I'm not sure how but it does
speak glowingly of her to everyone even on the day she has infuriated
you inflate you have landed the loveliest girl walking the
earth be a friend to her brother be a brother to
him help him out if he needs it and give him the opportunity to help you call him for no
reason and drop by with her on days you may not feel like it to make sure they stay connected.
If her brother is telling a story about me in which I seem especially annoying. Please feel free
to poke fun. I want them to take comfort in the fact they share a mother that is
only theirs and a childhood as wild and special as they are I need them
to have each other it's almost all I
need my brothers have protected and championed me in ways that she will need
also my own brother came to the bus stop with me when he learned I wasn't getting a seat because of
my rampant. Unpopularity. He stood there arms folded as though he
were barring everyone from entering the rest of their
lives if they did not comply with his wish to treat me with respect he
said nothing but stared into the face of every kid on that street corner promising that
their futures were going to remain in question unless they understood all
conversations stopped one person's not to look at it at another in his head with Duran
and to catch both of them incredulously looking at one another try
me his eyes said and don't think I
want the bus pulled up. I got in line and looked at him
still standing there with barely contained galvanic or I tried to convey
my thanks his eyes said back. That's how much.
Mary Louise Parker thank you thank you I can't read the rest and I don't
write thirty so I
thank
you very least for dear Mr you sank
your thanks so
much.